[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance so how does this all end with
the caveat that the last 21 months has
taught us that literally almost any
outcome you can think of seems to have
about a 5% chance of happening
I believe the newest developments
specifically Trump's healthcare Fiasco
and the clarifying picture of the
Russian scandal may have provided a
template the two likeliest outcomes and
something else new gives a grim
foretaste of a possible third outcome
firstly obviously there's Russia this is
a spike strip down the road in front of
Trump Bellini's Joyride we just don't
know how big the spike strip is nor how
far away and thus we don't know if the
correct metaphor for what Trump is
driving when he hits it is this or this
Russia could end Trump's administration
in a day or it could take the length of
an impeachment which we have seen in our
lifetimes plus a serious trial which we
have not or it could merely reach a kind
of unresolved stasis that would d
legitimate government until the midterms
or until 2020 the second outcome might
result from Russia or might exist
entirely independent of it but either
way the shape of it was presented to us
by Trump's Obamacare disaster sixty-four
days into the presidency of the first
new Republican nominee elected since
2000 on the issues so central to the
entire Republican Party for seven
uninterrupted years that its members in
the House voted 60 times to do it Trump
and the GOP could not repeal or replace
or alter or modify or touch or even get
a vote on Obamacare they not only
screwed up the proverbial one-car
funeral
the one-car funeral ended in a fiery
fatal collision more importantly what is
nominally his own party backed away from
Trump at the first sign of stress the 15
furthest to the right bailed on him the
15 furthest to the left bailed on him
suddenly he was the leader of the
minority in the house and they were
running for high ground and then after
investing nearly a couple of hours of
political capital
on it after running the gamut of
deal-making from A to B this new quote
president unquote gave up he even got a
roll of stamps and mailed in his
favorite part of this blaming people he
left that to somebody on Fox News and
not even one of the weeknight clowns big
bad wolf Trump's mouthpiece for revenge
against Paul Ryan was Jeanine Pirro
previously best known for calling a news
conference at the Waldorf Astoria Hotel
in New York to declare her candidacy for
the Republican nomination against
then-senator Hillary Clinton who
promptly got to page 10 of her speech
only to find that page missing she then
stopped asked if anybody had page 10 and
until it was handed to her waited in
excruciating silence for 32 seconds in
short with nothing to stop them but
their own disunity the Republicans opted
immediately for disunity what happens if
the Russia scandal explodes on Trump
what if more and more of his base
abandons Trump for whatever reason what
if his approval rating drops to 30
percent or 25 or 20 what happens is what
happened to Richard Nixon Richard Nixon
wasn't forced from the White House by
Democrats they controlled the House and
the Senate every day Nixon was in office
they had already presented the most
dramatic Senate special committee in
history they had stalled and stalled
installed before even mentioning
impeachment in the house now Nixon was
forced from office only as the 1974
midterms loomed and Republicans like
senator Barry Goldwater and House
Minority Leader John Rhodes
presumably calculated that Nixon staying
meant Republicans up for re-election in
three months like them would be going
you think these Republicans are going to
defend Donald Trump the moment he
becomes a tangible direct threat to
their re-election in 2018 they didn't
defend Donald Trump still the beacon for
their most rabid constituents on their
own party's primary rallying cry while
they were capable of passing anything
they wanted in the house by
before votes after the rasputin of
Pennsylvania Avenue Steve Bannon
reportedly threatened reprisals and a
[ __ ] list and nearly 20 months before
the midterms there is no Republican
loyalty to Trump now what about later if
Trump's insanity can no longer be hidden
it will be the Republicans who force him
into the straitjacket of the 25th
amendment and if Trump's disloyalty to
this country or just his political
toxicity can no longer be hidden it will
be the Republicans who impeach him not
the Democrats and then they'll all stand
around and say Trump Trump who of course
there is one other way all this ends on
the off chance neither of the first two
scenarios arise and we saw that over the
weekend - these are the anti-corruption
protests in Russia
hundreds arrested including the leader
of the political opposition scoff if you
want that we could ever see this in this
country but eighteen of the states of
our union are now working to expand the
criminalization of protests and more
importantly to increase financial
liability for dissent to say nothing of
Trump's own paranoia about paid
protesters and thugs and law and order
and more broadly if the wholesale
roundup of Democrats and liberals and
just pro-democracy protesters say two
years from today after the midterms if
that seems like political science
fiction to you think about two years ago
today what term in March 2015 would you
have used for the prediction the two
years ahead in our beloved country the
President of the United States would be
Donald Trump how would you have
described that if not by dismissing it
as political science fiction resist
peace